Ich schaue.
Okay.
Hallo.
Justof ist mein Name.
Ich bin zuständige Arzt jetzt.
Erst mal nehmen Sie Platz bitte.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Olaf Holthkamp.
Olaf Holthkamp.
Könnten Sie Ihr Nachname langsam
stabilieren?
Ja, Holthkamp schreibt sich
H-O-L-T-K-A-M-P
Holthkamp.
Ja, Holthkamp.
Ja.
Herr Holthkamp.
Wie kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit gestern
starke Schmerzen
im linken Unterschenkel und im Fuß.
Seit gestern?
Ja.
Welche Seite war es genau?
Im linken Unterschenkel und Fuß.
Im linken Unterschenkel.
So.
Wie hat es angefangen,
Ihr Schmerzen?
Langsamer oder plötzlich?
Ich hatte schon
in den Wochen vorher
oder circa 30 Wochen
vorher Schmerzen beim Gehen.
Wenn ich begangen bin,
dann tat plötzlich auch das linke
der linke Unterschenkel weh
und da musste ich immer anhalten
und stoppen.
Und danach ging es wieder etwas besser.
Ja.
Und im Ruhr haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit gestern tut es auch in Ruhe weh.
Alles klar.
Ich habe es auch in Ruhe weh.
Und
strahlen die Schmerzen
in eine andere Körperregion aus
oder
nur im linken Unterschenkel und im Fuß?
Nur im Unterschenkel und im Fuß.
Im Fuß auch.
Wie beschreiben Sie
die Schmerzen
eher drückend, brennend
oder...
Ja, ist mehr drückend.
Drückend.
Wie
stark
ist die Schmerz?
Können Sie
bis ein der unsere Gespresse
aushalten oder brauchen Sie
ein Schmerzmittel?
Ich habe zu Hause schon
eine Schmerztablette genommen.
Vor ungefähr 2 Stunden.
Aber das hat nicht so viel gebracht.
Aber ich kann noch etwas aushalten.
Können Sie sagen,
welche Tablette
haben Sie genommen?
Paracetamol.
500 steht da drauf.
500.
Aber hat es nichts gelegt?
Nein, hat nicht viel verändert.
Auf eine Schmerzskala
werden Sie messen würden
die Schmerzen
von 1 bis
1 für am leichtesten
und 10 für unverträglichen
Schmerzen entspricht.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen
einstufen?
Ja, 7 bis 8.
7 bis 8.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie etwas
bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen verursacht
oder gibt es etwas,
dass die Schmerzen
verstärken
oder...
Gestern war es wieder so,
wie die Wochen vorher, wenn ich gehe,
dann fangen die Schmerzen
nach wenigen Metern an.
Normalerweise hören Sie dann auf,
wenn ich stoppe, wenn ich anhalte.
Aber gestern,
seit gestern ist das nicht mehr so.
Seit gestern bleiben die Schmerzen.
Ja, seit gestern
ist es andauernd geworden.
Ja, gestern ist es ein Dauerschmerz.
So, haben Sie früher
so eine Schmerz
oder das ist das
erst mal aufgetreten?
In der Stärke jetzt seit gestern,
dieser Ruhe-Schmerz
seit gestern zum ersten Mal.
Vorher hatte ich die Schmerzen beim Gehen.
Alles klar.
Waren Sie deswegen
beim Hausarzt?
Nee, bisher noch nicht.
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt machen,
aber wenn ich bisher noch nicht zurückkomme.
Und
haben Sie mit
diese Schmerzen
noch andere Beschwerden?
Körperlich
oder
Ich habe so ein Beispiel.
Ich habe meine anderen Erkrankungen,
weshalb ich Tabletten nehmen muss.
Nein, ich meine
zum Beispiel hatten Sie
Fieber oder Stüffrost
nach Kaltschweiß.
Das habe ich nicht.
Oder haben Sie in der letzte Zeit
ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Ich wiege etwas zu viel,
aber
habe ich keine Veränderung gespürt.
Ja, ich meine,
undgewollte Schnamen.
Nein.
Oder
hatten Sie Herzgrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein,
habe ich auch nicht.
Sie sind
gut.
So, oder
haben Sie sich erbrochen
oder war Ihnen über?
Nein.
Ich habe die letzte Nacht nicht so gut geschlafen
wegen der Schmerzen.
Ja.
Oder haben Sie Husten?
Ja, ich habe Husten immer wieder,
weil ich auch ziemlich viel rauche.
Aber das ist eine
andauernde Husten?
Nein, nicht andauernd, aber
immer wieder habe ich so Reih zu Husten.
Ja.
Mit
Sputum
oder mit Auswurf
und trocken Husten eher.
Das ist mehr trocken, der Hust.
Seit wann haben Sie
die?
Also, Husten habe ich,
ich rauche ja schon ziemlich lange.
Ja, Husten habe ich bestimmt
jetzt schon, diesen Reih zu Husten seit 20 Jahren.
Alles klar.
Seit wann rauchen Sie
seit 20 Jahren?
Aber wie viel rauchen?
Ich rauche schon seit 45 Jahren.
Wie oft
am Tag?
Wie viele Zige
Wie viele genau?
Eine Packung.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends eine Flasche Bier
und manchmal
manchmal auch einen Schnaps,
aber das ist vielleicht in der Woche
zweimal.
Haben Sie Kontakt
mit trocken?
Nein.
Jetzt
haben Sie keine
Schluckwäschwerden oder Schluckschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Oder haben Sie
alles klar?
Haben Sie nicht Herzrasen gemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gibt es denn
vorgeschlichte,
welche
Erkrankungen
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was meinen Sie so zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel
Zuckerkrankheit
eröffnete Blutdruck
oder Schlaganfall
oder leiden Sie unter einer chronischen
Krankheit?
Hohe Blutfette
und hohes
Kollesterin.
Dann habe ich hohen Blutdruck
und ich habe auch
erhöhte
Harnsäure. Ich hatte schon 2-mal
Gichtanfall.
Leiden Sie unter
erhöhten Blutfettwerte?
Seit
15 Jahren.
15.
Ja.
Und Blutdruckdruck?
Seit wann?
Blutdruckdruck schon länger, seit 20 Jahren.
Diese Gicht
leiden Sie
zweimal.
Ich habe mal
einen großen Zehr
und gelenkt. Das tat sehr weh.
Wie hat es behandelt?
Das wurde damals
mit Tabletten behandelt
und das wurde dann im Laufe der Tage
dann besser und jetzt muss ich ja auch immer
noch eine Tablette nehmen,
damit die Harnsäure
gesenkt wird.
Welche Tablette darf ich fragen?
Sie meinen
für die Harnsäure oder für den Blutdruck?
Ja.
Natürlich.
Ich werde alles fragen.
Aber jetzt
gegen die Harnsäure,
halb-o-re-nol 300
eine Tablette morgens.
Und gegen
Blutdruckdruck?
Da nehme ich
Kandisatan
8 Milligramm steht da drauf.
Nämlich morgens
eine Tablette und abends
eine halbe.
Und dann
dann nehme ich noch etwas gegen
die Blutfette, gegen die
Cholesterin.
Dann nehme ich noch
Simvastatin
10 Milligramm.
Eine Abends.
Alles klar.
Wurde sie schon mal operiert?
Erholt kommt?
Ja, ich wurde schon mal vor
ich weiß nicht wie viele Jahre,
aber in ca. 8 Jahren
wurde ich schon mal an der Bandscheibe operiert.
Da hatte ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Wo genau
von Hals
oder von Läden?
Und in der Lendenwirbelsäule.
Ich glaube, das heißt glaube ich
11,5.
Ich weiß nicht genau mehr.
Das war auf der linken Seite.
Und gab es
Komplikationen?
Ja, ich habe noch mal am
Blinteram operiert worden.
Da war ich 18 Jahre alt.
Alles klar.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergie
oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, ich vertrage
alles.
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Das freut mich.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja.
Ich war vor einem Jahr
beim Hausarzt
zur Gesundheitsuntersuchung.
Da
sagte eben,
Blutdruck ist nicht immer gut eingestellt.
Geimpft bin ich.
Ausreichend.
Covid-19 3-mal geimpft.
Ich habe auch eine Vorsorge
Darmspiegelung machen lassen.
Vor einem Jahr die Weinordnungen.
Können Sie
die letzte
Satz nochmal wiederholen?
Ich habe eine Darmspiegelung machen lassen.
Als Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Bei meinem Hausarzt
habe ich eine Darmspiegelung geschickt.
Das war in Ordnung.
Gab es dort etwas auffälliges?
Nein.
Das war ein Ordnung.
Alles klar.
Jetzt möchte ich
einige
Fragen über Ihr Familie stellen.
Ja.
Leben Ihr Eltern noch?
Der Vater
ist mit 80
Jahren an einem Schlaganfall
verstorben.
Die Mutter
lebt noch.
Sie ist 92 Jahre alt.
Sie hat etwas hohen Blutdruck
und etwas Alterszucker.
Aber mehr weiß ich darüber nicht.
Wie viel
haben Sie?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist 2 Jahre jünger als ich.
Er
hat
auch mit Gicht zu tun
und hat hohen Blutdruck.
Hochblutdruck.
Aber ich habe vergessen, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin
64 Jahre alt.
Ja, und waren genau sind Sie gewohnt?
Am 15. April
1958.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
81 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Alles klar.
Herr Holkamp,
was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich habe es vor einem Jahr
als Maurer gearbeitet.
Auf dem Bau.
Aber seit einem Jahr bin ich pensioniert.
Sie sind Rentner geworden?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja.
Ich bin ein Familienstand.
Ich bin ein
Ja,
einen Sohn.
Er ist 35 Jahre alt.
Er hat etwas Probleme
mit dem Gewicht.
Er ist auch etwas zu schwer, zu dick.
Sonst ist er gesund.
Mit wem leben Sie zurzeit?
Mit meiner Frau.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit
im Ausland
oder haben Sie eine lange Reise?
Was heißt in der Zeit?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Im letzten Wochen
oder Monat?
Nein, war ich nicht im Ausland.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein.
Ich schaue nur Fußball im Fernsehen.
Sehr gut.
Herr Holkamp,
sind wir fertig?
Unser Gespräch?
Ja,
ich bin sehr gut.
Herr Holkamp,
ich bin fertig.
Unser Gesprächs.
Ich gehe bei Ihnen
von einem Verdacht
auf das Schaufenster-Krankheit.
Aber das ist nur ein
Verdacht.
Und es muss
bestätigt werden.
Ja.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich
untersuchen.
Nachdem ich mit meinem
Kollegen
eine Rucalto gemacht habe.
Und
werde ich von Ihnen
Blut abnehmen.
Und machen wir
ein Ultraschall
von Ihre
Unterschenke.
Ja, sehr gut.
So machen wir weiter.
Alles klar?
Gut, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Nein,
ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Holkamp,
haben Sie bemerkt,
Ihre linken Beinhaut,
dass Sie etwas geschwollt
und waren kalt oder gerötet
sind?
Nein, war eher das Bein der Unterschenke,
war in letzter Zeit etwas kalt.
Okay.
Ihre linken Bein etwas taubhaft gefühlt,
Kraftlosigkeit,
haben Sie bemerkt?
Nicht so richtig.
Sie sind kalt und beim Gehen
schmerzt.
Müssen Sie sich beim Gehen
Hilfe holen?
Oder linken Sie beim Gehen?
Linken Sie beim Gehen?
Die ersten Meter nicht,
aber nach ca. 50 Metern
kam der Schmerz so stark,
dann musste ich anhalten,
musste ich mich hinsetzen.
Sie haben 50 Meter
Gehen.
Ca. 50 Meter.
Und gestern
hörte der Schmerz
nicht mehr auf.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Eine Kollegin
hat gefragt.
Nein, unvollhärtig nicht.
Hab ich diese Frage?
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Gut.
Können wir
Arsatzgespräche anfangen,
Jusuf?
Bitte nur eine Minute.
Ich komme sofort.
Hallo Herr Doktor.
Hatten Sie
kurze Zeit für mich?
Ich bin der neue Arzt.
Ich möchte ein Patient vorstellen.
Herr Holkampf Olaf.
64-Jährige Patient.
Hat sich heute bei uns
wegegehen.
Ich bin der neue Arzt.
Hat sich heute bei uns wegehen.
Seit gestern
aufgetretene
Linken
unter Schenkel
Schmerzen
vorgestellt
und
er
beschrieb die
Schmerzen
eher drückend
auf eine Schmerzskala
Lege 7 bis 9 von. Hat er die Schmerzen früher schon mal gehabt? So eine Schmerzen hatte er nicht,
aber früher habe bei Belastung ähnliche Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark. Und was für eine Belastung ist das?
Beim Gehen hatte er nach 50 Metern, habe er anfangen zu hinken. Seit gestern habe er auch im Ruhr diese
Kladikasio. Gibt es Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten? Ja, der Patient ist eine starke Raucher, er
raucht seit 45 Jahren ein Packung Zigarette und das spricht dafür und auch seine Alta.
Gibt es sonst Risikofaktoren noch im Stoffwechselbereich? Er hat auch früher zweimal Lichtanfälle,
das auch spricht dafür. Die Einnahme von Paracetomol 400 mg, habe keine Linderung gebracht.
Und andere Risikofaktoren wie Hypertonus? Gibt es noch andere Risikofaktoren bei dem Patient?
Er leide auch an Hyprecholesterniemi und Pacellia Hypertoni.
Gut, da kommen jetzt ja einige Risikofaktoren zusammen. Gibt es eine auffällige Familie in Alamnese?
Sein Vater ist an Schlag angestoren.
An Apoplex? Ja, an Apoplex.
Bei Mutter auch Atelierhypertoni und Diabetes sind bekannt.
Und auch bei seinem Bruder, auch Atelierhypertoni.
Wer muss für eine Verdachtstiagnose haben Sie?
Ich habe bei dieser Patient von einem Verdacht aus PRVK, sogenannte Schaufensterkrankheit aus.
PRVK, Schaufensterkrankheit oder die Symptomatik in den Wochen vorher als Clodication Intermittence?
Ja, genau. Die Fernseher diagnostisch kommen vielleicht TVT oder noch den Gift im Betracht.
Patient vor Operationen?
Vor Operationen hatte er wegen Lerndenwebelsäule, Syndrome operiert, 115 Links vor 8 Jahren und ein Appendectomie im Alter von 18 durchgeführt.
Kann diese Schmerzsymptomatik mit einer erneuten Problematik von der Bandscheibe im Bein herrühren?
Es muss auch berücksichtigt werden.
Was spricht gegen einen Discospolaps?
Das spricht dafür oder dagegen?
Ich glaube der Patient hat die Schmerzen im gesamten Unterschenkel beschrieben und nicht segmental.
Das spricht nicht unbedingt für eine Bandscheibenproblematik.
Aber man muss es zumindest im Betracht ziehen. Der Patient ist voroperiert.
Auch am linken, auf der linken Seite.
Wichtig ist, dass sie konsequent versuchen, die Gesundheitsstörungen in Fachbegriffe umzusetzen.
Der Patient hat eine Hyperlipidemi und Hypercholesterinemi, hat eine Hypertoni und eine Hyperurikämie und Zustand nach Arthritisurica zweimalig.
Das ist wichtig, das zu transformieren in das Arztgespräch.
PAVK, völlig in Ordnung.
Die Verdachtdiagnose würde ich jetzt auch nach ihrer Schilderung erst mal stellen.
Die Vorgeschichte spricht dafür, drei Monate lang hatte er Symptome im Sinne einer Clodicatiointermittenz.
Und seit gestern ist es einen Dauerschmerz übergegangen.
Also muss wahrscheinlich irgendwo ein Gefäß jetzt richtig zugegangen sein.
Und er hat die Risikofaktoren einer Hypercholesterinemi, einer Nikotinabusus über 45 Jahre.
Das würde ich ruhig als Begriff sagen. Fortgesetzter Nikotinabusus über 45 Packageers.
Okay, im Anfang haben Sie vergessen eben, das haben Sie dann korrigiert.
Sie haben den Namen erfragt, Sie haben aber nicht das Alter erfragt und Geburtstatum und die metrischen Datengewicht.
Und ich denke, das sollte ganz oben im Anfang stehen, so im Kopf.
Man hat schon mal einen gewissen Überblick, wie alt ist der Patient, der ist ja übergewichtig und so weiter.
Ja, ich war mir nicht sicher, ob beide Patient eine akut aufgetretene Schmerz sind.
Wie zum Beispiel Myokraterinfarkt.
Ich möchte erst mal ein Herzinfarkt ausschließen, deswegen gehe ich sofort nach Beschwerden.
Ja, also okay, gut, dann kann man aber zurücknehmen, wenn der Patient sagt, ich habe seit gestern Schmerzen mit Lincoln Unterschenkel und im Fuß.
Das ist ja nun für einen Akute-Erreignis-Kardial unwahrscheinlich.
Aber einfach nur daran denken, dann diese Daten möglichst schnell zu erfassen und nicht erst am Ende der Anamnese.
Na, Sie haben recht.
Das ist für, wahrscheinlich macht das einen besseren Eindruck.
Na, genau.
Und wie gesagt, konsequentes Umsetzen der Patientensprache in die medizinischen Fachausdruck.
Gut.
Herzlichen Dank.